This is our specific
pathogen-free facility.
This is where we keep
all of our clean stocks
that we use in our research
and that we used as controls
for any challenge studies.
So these animals are
completely free of disease.
We get live animals
from all over the world.
We get them from Asia.
We come from South America.
We've gotten them
from Saudi Arabia.
There's very few countries
we haven't got them from that
are actively raising shrimp.
It's a unique location,
really, because when
you're working on diseases
of aquatic animals,
one of the things
that you don't want
is to spread the disease
in natural environment.
And fortunately, we are
located in a unique position,
because there is no
natural water bodies
hundreds of miles from here.
One of our key missions
is to provide disease
diagnostic service to
shrimp industry globally.
So farmers, shrimp
farmers, worldwide, they
send shrimp samples to
our lab for the disease
diagnostic purpose.
And we carry out all
kinds of disease detection
work in our lab and provide
them with the results.
So we need to make sure
that these animals are
free of diseases,
because we don't
want to spread the disease
inadvertently or even
knowingly.
Shrimp industry is
very big in countries
with large coastal
boundaries, particularly
in the North and South
America, as well as in Asia.
So it provides jobs for millions
of people around the world.
And in many countries,
shrimp is one
of the major sources of earning
revenues for the nation.
We also provide services
to shrimp industry globally
in terms of carrying
out some basic research,
like, say, a company
wants to develop
an antiviral or
antimicrobial therapy.
And we preform all
those experiments.
So it's a wonderful
opportunity for us
to interact with researchers
globally and also train them
so that we collectively
can serve the industry
and make shrimp
farming sustainable.